grün hand die kapitalistisch freitags
auf der klima demo und natürlich fans
des gender sternchens des tempolimits
von hipster cafés die latte und latte
macchiato mit harper milch lassen grüßen
genau das mögen junge leute
blödsinnig
gut ok spätestens seit der
bundestagswahl 2021 ist klar dass junge
menschen deutlich unterschiedlicher
ticken als viele vorher vermutet hätten
dass große klischee von generation greta
ist endgültig überholt wir zeigen euch
jetzt was die fakten zu jungen leuten
tatsächlich sagen und warum wir alle
einen differenzierten blick auf sie
werfen sollten
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
neuen video unserer reihe politbarometer
to go verratet uns bei den kommentaren
welche klischees über junge menschen ihr
so richtig satt habt einfach unten rein
schreiben ich bin sehr gespannt was da
so zusammenkommt so und wie junge leute
ticken zu denen ich mich mit mitte 30
sogar noch mal ja sagen wir halbwegs
zähle zumindest wenn man mal schaut
wieder altersschnitt im neuen bundestag
ist das schauen wir uns in drei
schritten an erstens was verraten uns
die ergebnisse der bundestagswahl in
bezug auf die interessen junger menschen
was kann man daraus lesen zweitens
welche sorgen probleme und hoffnungen
haben junge menschen heute insgesamt und
warum haben sie vielleicht so gewählt
die sie gewählt haben und dann wäre da
noch der dritte punkt wie geht es jetzt
weiter wie könnten junge menschen in
zukunft wählen 40 alles ändern wird
alles komplett anders schauen wir uns
zuerst mal das wahlverhalten der unter
30-jährigen an 22 prozent wählten die
grünen und 19 prozent die fdp nur damit
niemand das versteht es gibt natürlich
das wahlgeheimnis ist niemand weiß genau
welche stimme von dem abgegeben wurde
und man kann das auch nicht danach
auswerten die zahlen basieren auf daten
der forschungsgruppe wahlen die haben
wahlberechtigte zufällig ausgewählt und
befragt das ganze ist repräsentativ und
daher können wir die daten hier als
grundlage nehmen wer jetzt aber denkt
das war schon immer so die grünen und
die fdp sind bei erstwählern einfach
generell total beliebt der täuscht sich
erreicht ein blick auf die
bundestagswahl 2017 noch vor vier jahren
bei unter den jungen wählern mit abstand
die union am beliebtesten zumindest
gaben 25 prozent der 18 bis 19 80
jährigen an die partei gewählt zu haben
oder die beiden parteien
2021 liegen aber die grünen auf platz
eins mit 22 prozent knapp vor der fdp
mit 19 prozent also kann man mit
sicherheit sagen dass das die zwei
beliebtesten parteien bei jungen
menschen sind gerade diese parteien die
sich nun nicht wirklich absolut ähnlich
sind und in einigen punkten ganz
unterschiedliche zielsetzungen haben das
ist durchaus überraschend fdp und grüne
sind also die großen gewinner bei jungen
leuten allgemein aber und das sollte man
im großen und ganzen auch nicht
vergessen die beiden parteien machen
insgesamt nur 41 prozent aus wie bei den
unter 30-jährigen wenn man die beiden
werte zusammenzählt der restliche teil
der jungen leute ist verteilt auf alle
weiteren parteien und auch auf die die
nicht gewählt haben je nach bundesland
kann es sei eben auch große unterschiede
geben auch die verschiedenen
landtagswahlen im jahr 2021 haben
gezeigt dass junge menschen
verschiedener sind als es der eine oder
die andere glaubt oder man immer mal
wieder suggeriert bekommt die fdp war
bei der landtagswahl in sachsen anhalt
bei den unter 25 jährigen mit 17 prozent
die zweitstärkste partei ok jetzt haben
sie schon eine ganze menge zahlen
betrachtet und wir merken dass junge
menschen sehr unterschiedlich wählen
dass sie unterschiedlich ticken jetzt
schauen wir uns mal an was gerade den
erfolg der fdp der für viele in der form
überraschend war erklären könnte was
steckt dahinter wie kam das zusammen
wichtig ist mir an der stelle zu
erwähnen dass da derzeit die analysen
noch laufen und es sowieso schwierig ist
zu erklären warum der oder die einzelne
so gewählt hat wie es passiert ist das
ist natürlich eine völlig individuelle
sache deshalb versuchen wir uns einfach
damit zu beschäftigen was junge menschen
generell bewegt und wie das zum
wahlkampf der parteien passt und
letztendlich auch zur wahlentscheidung
womit hängt das eine zusammen was ist
die ursache des anderen die aktuellste
jugendstudie die sich dazu finden lässt
ist die analyse junge deutsche 2021 sie
basiert auf einer repräsentativen online
befragung von personen im alter von 14
bis 39 jahren dabei werden vor allem
fünf punkte genannt die junge menschen
von der politik erwarten erster junge
menschen mehr beteiligen und das
wahlalter senken zweitens schulen und
schulsystem modernisieren besseres
internet drittens klimaschutz viertens
mehr miteinander und fünftens eine
ökosoziale wirtschaft der autor der
studie und jugendforscher simon
schmetzer erklärt mit welchen punkten
fdp und grüne ganz besonders gut
ankommen genau der wohlstand spiel eben
eine sehr große rolle es ist nicht nur
dieses thema freiheit wobei natürlich
die freiheit die einschränkung der
freiheit in zeiten der pandemie
ein die vorlage für den großen vorwurf
auch gegen die große koalition war aber
das thema
rente zum beispiel kommt stärker dann
hast du jetzt geld auf dem konto und du
bekommst plötzlich - zinsen dass das
triggert etwas bei der jungen generation
wo sie sagt so ok geht's weiter wer hat
da lösungen für uns und da da ist die
fdp sehr glaubwürdig rüber gekommen und
sie waren natürlich auch präsent so wie
man es halt mit klassischen plakaten
aufgebracht in den ruhestand geht man
wohlstands verhohlen mit dem ärmeren
viertel mit anderen und genau das hat
die fdp in sozialen netzwerken auch
gemacht sie haben junge leute gezielt
angesprochen mit den passenden botschaft
klima
wohlstand zukunft die unternehmer haben
sie angesprochen mit niedrige steuern
und so weiter sie haben schön ihre
botschaften
platziert und auch differenziert die
frage ist gibt es auch unterschiede
zwischen den geschlechtern
darüber haben wir mit matthias jung
gesprochen von der forschungsgruppe
wahlen wir haben ganz ja immer auch in
der vergangenheit vor allem bei jungen
frauen ist sehr hohe aktivität zugunsten
der grünen gehabt das hängt unter
anderem natürlich auch damit zusammen
dass dann das ich in dieser altersgruppe
zum beispiel auch die frage der
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
müsse deutlich darstellt und da auch die
frage wie können kinder
auch durch zusätzliche einrichtung
staatlicher art neben betreut werden das
ist nach wie vor so dass dass frauen
stärker tangiert als männer die sich da
ein bisschen raus definieren und wir
haben umgekehrt eine stärkere
wirtschafts orientieren aufstiegs
orientierung bei jüngeren männern und da
spielen dann eben fragen der
freizügigkeit und auch fragen zum
beispiel der
digitalisierung noch größere rolle als
es bei den entsprechend jungen
weiblichen bildern ist wenn wir über den
erfolg der fdp sprechen dann kommen wir
um das thema freiheit sicher auch nicht
herum
gut david hasselhoff hat damit recht
wenig zu tun aber dafür eher die
tatsache dass die fdp vor der wahl
speziell während der zeit des lok downs
immer wieder die eingeschränkte freiheit
vor allem von jungen menschen betont hat
und die freien demokraten werden schon
länger mit genau diesen kern thema in
verbindung gebracht auch weil sie es
sich immer wieder auf die fahne
schreiben wir haben zum beispiel
festgestellt eben dass die fdp ja auch
immer sehr
kritisch fungiert hat und auch die
anhängerschaft der fdp kritischer
eingestellt waren gegenüber den
staatlichen corona maßnahmen als dass zb
die wählerschaft von grünen spd und
union waren die fdp hatte dass so eine
zwischenposition zwischen
eben diesen drei
parteien und der afg und da war zwar
nicht unbedingt jetzt position von
corona erläutern zu finden aber doch
eine sehr große reserviertheit gegen
staatliche eingriffe in diesem bereich
beginn dieses videos hier haben wir
gesagt kleides for future spielt eine
rolle und der klimaschutz ist den leuten
die die fdp gewählt haben das egal
jungen menschen oder auch männern die
fdp wählen ist klimaschutz nicht egal
das finde ich ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt es ging nicht darum ich quäle die
grünen oder ich entscheide mich gegen
klimaschutz und für wohlstand mit der
fdp also junge menschen die sich
zwischen den parteien entschieden haben
haben nicht gesagt für oder gegen
klimaschutz sondern
welche call welches konzept von
klimaschutz oder
ist aus meiner sicht dass zukunftsfähige
und da gab es eben unterschiede und
daher haben sich ein paar von den von
den grünen abgewandt weil sie sagen das
ist so eine art öko tourismus
utopismus ich glaube nicht dass das
konzept so funktioniert ja und wie geht
es weiter wie könnten junge menschen zur
bundestagswahl 2025 29 oder auch 33
wählen ist das ein trend oder ein
einmaliger moment wählen junge menschen
irgendwann konservativ und nicht mehr
fdp oder grüne eine erste antwort darauf
ob auch junge menschen von heute genau
wie viele ältere von heute irgendwann
die spd oder die cdu wählen die csu gibt
in der wahlforschung der sogenannte
kohorten effekt der besagt dass nicht
das alter an sich ausschlaggebend dafür
ist wen oder was wir wählen sondern dass
menschen die in einer bestimmten zeit
geboren sind und auch aufgewachsen sind
in einer bestimmten richtung politisch
geprägt wurden und dementsprechend
parteipräferenzen bilden und ein leben
lang bestehen bleiben könnten dann die
bundestagswahlen in 30 bis 40 jahren so
aussehen dass grüne und fdp die größten
parteien sind weil viele junge wähler
jetzt sich auf diese parteien
einschießen sie immer wieder wählen
werden eine citrus regierung also na ja
da muss man auch sagen dass dieser
effekt schwächer zu werden scheint weil
es immer mehr wechselwähler unter uns
gibt die sich also auch mal ganz schnell
anders entscheiden dies vorher überhaupt
nicht wissen wen sie wählen sollen und
dann sehr spontan sind ist natürlich
auch ein bisschen kaffeesatzleserei
dabei aber für unser aller zukunft sehr
spannend und wir wollten sich auch nicht
vorenthalten lohnt sich darüber mal
gedanken zu machen also halten wir fest
junge menschen heute sind deutlich
unterschiedlicher als man denkt und von
pauschalisierungen sollte man sowieso
immer abstand nehmen auch wenn das gerne
mal vorgenommen wird weil es hilft
bestimmte dinge einzuordnen aber in
diesem fall greift das zu kurz und
übrigens kleiner fun fact zum schluss
denn latte macchiato ist gar nicht so
beliebt wie man vielleicht denkt gerade
mal zwei prozent der menschen in
deutschland trinken ihn mehrmals pro
woche und egal ob mit oder ohne kaffee
und kaffeesatzleserei findet ihr hier an
der seite jetzt ein weiteres video hier
auf dem kanal und direkt darunter findet
ihr was von meinem kanal mister wissen
zugang auch zu einem thema aus diesem
bereich und übrigens latte macchiato
trinke ich überhaupt nicht mag nämlich
kein kaffee danke fürs zuschauen und bis
zum nächsten